als das geld in auf dem kopf schwebender
geist der fliegt einfach mal weg
verbindet kribbelt mir hey leute und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft fact das ist eine serie falls
ihr das doch kennt bald sehr lange nicht
gekommen ist wo ich euch immer 36 über
minecraft vorstelle die eventuell noch
nicht wusste so eine art unnützes wissen
halt und dann kommen noch immer ein fun
fact dazu der mega unnütz ist der halt
einfach wie gedacht so ein lustiger
effekt ist noch mal am ende den habe ich
im letzten folge vergessen allerdings
davor in den zehn milliarden leon 14
folgen hat immer gesagt und deswegen
wird dir auch so angefangen direkt an
mit dem ersten verhext und zwar braucht
ihr ein amboss dafür da machte dann ganz
einfach rechtzeitig drauf wenn hier zum
beispiel spawn schiebt könnte dass da
ein gehen dafür dir den namen ändern und
dann bekommt ihr ein schaf aus dem zum
beispiel den namen dann irgendwie luca
hat oder so wenn ihr allerdings grumman
ein gibt also gmm das mache ich jetzt
auch noch mal bei der crew genommen
da werdet ihr gleich schon sehen das ist
nicht ein ganz normaler name
sonderrechte jetzt mal hier alle drei
untereinander
die sind alle auf den kopf wenn ihr
irgendeine person dar einlegt oder
irgendein sports und ihr nennt es brummt
dann sind die alle auf dem kopf das ist
megageil
die sind einfach alle auf den kopf die
ganze zeit dürfte die schlagzahl ob die
schwimmen egal ob keine ahnung was die
gehen noch nicht und obwohl der kopf
eigentlich unter wasser ist und also es
ist echt hammer geil jetzt sagen
natürlich wieder alle hell macht dass
man mit dem karst t leute ich mache mit
dem gast dann werdet ihr auch was sehen
bekommen
ich nehme den ich muss hier in auf dem
kopf schweben damals der fliegt einfach
mal weg verpasste gebildeter kribbelt
mir dir
also seid wenn ihr irgendwo in den
amboss legt in das grand dann all die
tiere auf dem kopf das ist schon ein
bisschen crazy sich so kommen wir zu
effekt nummer zwei und zwar was selbst
der kleine wurde mir vorgeschlagen von
samuel aus 990 erkennt dass er im
creative ihr könnt ihr ganz normal
blogger abbauen hier bekommen wir alles
abbauen wieder hinsetzen blabla
allerdings wird es irgendwie verändert
mit dem schwert kann man das nicht mehr
machen mit dem schwert nur noch schlagen
das finde ich besonders sehr geil wenn
gerade mal einfach so die sonst regiert
neven wenn irgendwie ganz gleich wie die
tiere gespart hat und damals war es
immer so den alten effekt folgen sich
zum beispiel ganz ganz viele ozelot
sportart und die alle töten wollte da
hab ich dabei immer die halbe welt
kaputt gemacht weil hier umgeschlagen
habe übrigens wenn ihr das schwert ich
noch nicht kennt das werde ich beiträge
über machen was das ist da seht ihr ja
auch noch ein paar sachen ein bisschen
warten weil das ist sehr umfangreich
damit kann man jetzt keine blöcke mehr
kaputt machen weil einfach wenn man
tiere töten will hat man halt immer die
halbe welt kaputt gemacht und das auf
jeden fall der sehr geil so eine art
neuerung nicht so eine art fällt aber es
ist halt in einer gewissen weise auch
ein fact und ich will sagen gemacht
jetzt einfach mal mit drei weitere
schnell schnell schnell war das nur der
scheiße perfekt und ich bin hammer geil
wenn ihr das hier gerade hört dann
schreibt man alle jolo in die kommentare
und butter milch die geilen sound ihr
gerne google so meine lieben freunde
kommen wir zu effekt numero drei hat mir
beim race lp geschrieben meinte
allerdings das ist wahrscheinlich nur
mit dem die volltexte pack geht deswegen
mache ich das jetzt auch mit dem die
volltexte pack und zwar bald
unbeschriebenes buch hat also booking
grill oder buch und feder auf deutsch
und da ist einfach was rein schreiben
und zwar optisch bleibt verstehen immer
man kann im springen schreiben hatte ich
kann ihn springen schreiben also ein
kleiner 3.1 fake ist mehr ganz so
aufgefangen
naja egal und wenn man dieses zeichen
kopiert moment moment moment sieht man
gar nicht so richtig weiß ich nicht doch
vielleicht ein anderes texmex
weggebrochen
so hat ex monrose works
so sieht schon besser und zwar wenn ich
dieses zeichen warte ich schreib mal
entscheiden hier auch maniche kann solch
ein schritt in tetz schreiben ich
schreibe euch einmal die facts in die
kommentare das ist dieses paragraf
zeichen diese zwei übereinander dieses
buch ich mal euch das mal ganz kurz
darauf ich kann das jetzt gar nicht
verschlechtert klären ich mache das hier
mal eben so auf ich weiß nicht ob ihr
dieses zeichen kennt wahrscheinlich dass
schon wird im moment geben das denn
nochmal kindes nicht wieso so und dann
nochmal so ist es irgendwie areal so
sieht relativ außer dieses paragraf
zeichen wisst ihr ich kann das nur durch
steuerung v einfügen
wenn man das allerdings in buchrain
schreibt ein switch thema zwischen zwei
verschiedenen zahlen
also ich gehe jetzt zum beispiel ein bd
das zeichen und wenn ich dann
leerzeichen druck und ich kann halt
nicht mehrere hintereinander setzt sich
durch die ganze zeit steuerung vor und
es geht halt nicht wenn ich irgendwas
anderes steuerung vormache genannt und
buchstaben dann geht das alles aber das
hier ist einfach nur eine zwitschernde
zahl zwischen null und sieben weiße
schrift blabla ich kann ihr internet
schreiben hallo oder so aber es wird
halt immer direkt weg gemacht wenn ich
hier nach ingwer schreibe es wird halt
egal welche taste drückt es geht halt
sofort weg und es ist einfach und es
wird schon die zahl also sondern so ein
bisschen 'schon fun fact mäßig
allerdings ist der fun fact ein bisschen
anders den ich euch nicht vorstellen
werde aber auf jeden fall eine sache so
wo ihr sagen könnt so hey guck mal alter
das immer noch so krumm du meine lieben
freunde kommen wir zum fun fact und zwei
schritten mehr eine fun weckbach effekt
und zwar haben mir sehr viele leute
schon immer als korrekt geschrieben so
jahr guck mal hier man kann cheaten wenn
man sich mit dem kloster oder so in
seinen kopf rein weil man dann wenn man
da steht und man drückt den glos doch in
seinem kopf rein dass man dann halt so
ganz viele höhlen sehen kann und so was
alles so extreme mäßig halt allerdings
hatten die forscher welchen ich wollte
dass getötet oder sowas auf irgend
welchen servern und so was alles
deswegen hab ich das handy vorgestellt
allerdings darf ich euch nun vorstellen
möchte ist auch das ist behoben wurde
dass es nicht mehr geht also ich kann
mich zum beispiel hinstellen und man
wird halt einfach weggedrückt und man
kriegt das nicht mehr den kopf rein
sondern wird halt einfach weggedrückt
also das finde ich auf jeden fall sehr
cool dass sie das behoben haben dass da
keine leute mit schicken können das war
so der fun fun fact so mehr dass es
nicht mehr geht
ich würde sagen wenn ihr mehr effekt
volt und wollte sich das öfters
hochladen schreibt mir ganz ganz viel
effekt damit ich da ein paar gute habe
und gebt einfach einen daumen hoch und
ich weiß nicht schafft die community
unity das hat sich so abgefangen
community community schreibt die ft com
community 4404 die likes ich weiß es
nicht schafft er das freundin
aufmerksamer genannt wird dann keine
luft weg und beim nächsten mal wieder
die
mit